so where we left off we were looking at
this this parametric function for a
three-dimensional curve and what it
draws i showed you was a helix in
three-dimensional space and we're trying
to find its curvature which um and the
way you think about that you have a
circle you're thinking of the circle
that most closely hugs that curve or you
could imagine you know you're flying a
spaceship and all your all your
instruments lock up when you're turning
and you're wondering what circle in
space you're going to trace out and
you're looking for one divided by the
radius of that or if you prefer my you
know kindergarten or drawing skills you
can just look at the helix over here
while we work it through
and
the
the the part where we left off we have
this tangent vector function this unit
tangent vector function for our curve so
at every given value t whatever point
that corresponds to on the curve this
function is going to give us the vector
that is of unit length and tangent to
the curve
and the ultimate goal for curvature
is to find
the derivative
of that unit tangent vector with respect
to arc length
and that and specifically we want its
magnitude
and what that typically requires and i
talked about this in the videos on the
formula is you take its derivative with
respect to the parameter t because
that's the thing you can actually do
and that might not correspond to unit
length right if you nudge the parameter
t that might not nudge you a
corresponding
length on the curve but you correct that
by dividing out by the derivative
of the parameterization function with
respect to t
and that's actually arc length this
derivative the magnitude of the
derivative of the parameter
of the parameterization with respect to
t but is that a hard word um
so with our given function let's go
ahead and start doing that and i think
first given that we have this kind of
fractions of fractions form i'm just
going to start by writing it a little
bit more a little bit more simply so our
unit tangent vector function
that first component where we're
dividing by the square root of 26
divided by 5 instead i'm just going to
write that as
negative 5 times the sine of t so i'm
just kind of moving that 5 up into the
numerator divided by the root of 26
and i'll do the same thing for cosine
where we move that 5 up into the
numerator
cosine of t
divided by
the root
of 26
and then that last part 1 5 divided by
square root of 26 fifths gives us just 1
divided by
square root of 26.
all right so the first step in using our
curvature formula
is going to be to take the derivative of
this guy right we need the derivative of
the tangent vector function so we go
ahead and start doing that we see that
d big t
d little t so tangent vector function
parameter
is equal to and we just take the
derivative of each component
so negative 5 sine goes to negative 5
cosine
and we divide out by that constant
square root of 26.
similarly 5 cosine goes to negative 5
sine
since the derivative of cosine is
negative sine
negative 5 sine
divided by 26 or square root of 26
and that last component is just a
constant so derivative is nothing it's
zero
uh next step we're going to take the
magnitude of that vector that we just
found so we're trying to find the
magnitude of the derivative of the
tangent vector function
so we say all right
magnitude of what we just found d big t
d little t
involves
so this magnitude will be the square
root
uh make the little tick there square
root of the sum of the squares of these
guys so the square of that first
component
is going to be 25
multiplied by cosine squared
cosine squared of t
all divided by 26
right because the square root of the
square
the square of the square root of 26 is
26 and then we add to that um
25
times sine squared
sine squared of t
also divided by 26
and from that we can factor out
factor out 25 over 26
inside that radical
because both terms involve multiplying
by 25 and dividing by 26
and what we're left with is a nice and
friendly cosine sine pair
the reason we love things involving
circles this always happens nice
cancellation
this just becomes one so what we're left
with on the whole
is
root 25 over 26
pretty nice
root 25 over 26.
so for our curvature equation we go up
and we can start plugging that in so we
just found that numerator and found that
it was
the square root of 25
divided by 26
the entire thing 25 over 26
and we already found the magnitude of
the derivative itself that's one of the
things we needed to do to find the
tangent vector that's where that's where
this
26 over 5 came from i deleted it from
where we did last video to make room but
if you look at the last video you can
see where we got that
square root of 26 divided by 5. and i'll
actually write that as
square root of
26
divided by 25
just you know that's how we originally
found it i'm just putting the 5 back
under the radical
and it's tempting if you if you aren't
looking too closely to think these guys
cancel out but it's actually they're the
opposite of each other right one is 25
over 26 the other is 26 over 25.
so if we put everything under the
radical there so i'm going to say equals
the square root
and we're going to have 25 over 26
divided by
26
over 25
and when we flip that bottom and
multiply
what we get
is 25 squared
divided by 26 squared
and the root of that whole thing
just gives us 25
over 26
and that is our curvature that right
there is the answer that's the curvature
so it's a little bit greater than one no
no sorry that's a so it's a little bit
less than one which means that you're
curving a little bit less than you would
if it was a circle with radius one which
kind of makes sense if we if we look at
the image here because if the helix were
completely flattened out right if you
imagine squishing this down onto the x y
plane you'd just be going around a
circle with radius one but by kind of
pulling that spring and pulling it so
that there's a z component you're making
a little bit more straight so the
curvature should go down a little bit
because it's becoming a little bit more
straight the radius of curvature will go
up
so that's the curvature of a helix and
that's a pretty good example of how you
can find the curvature by walking
through directly the idea of finding
dtds and you know getting that unit
tangent vector getting that little unit
arc length
and in the next in the next example i
think i'll go through one where you just
use the formula where it's something a
little bit more complicated than
thinking about this and you and you turn
to the formula itself and i'll see you
then